- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is see that if we have
two different triangles,
and we have two sets
of corresponding sides
that have the same length,
for example this blue
side has the same length
as this blue side here,
and this orange side
has the same length side
as this orange side here.
And the angle that is
formed between those sides,
so we have two corresponding
angles right over here,
that they also have the equal measure.
So we could think about
we have a side, an angle,
a side, a side, an angle and a side.
If those have the same
lengths or measures,
then we can deduce
that these two triangles must be congruent
by the rigid motion
definition of congruency.
Or the short hand is,
if we have side, angle, side in common,
and the angle is between the two sides,
then the two triangles will be congruent.
So to be able to prove this,
in order to make this deduction,
we just have to say that there's always
a rigid transformation if we have
a side, angle, side in common
that will allow us to map
one triangle onto the other.
Because if there is a series
of rigid transformations
that allow us to do it,
then by the rigid
transformation definition
the two triangles are congruent.
So the first thing that we could do
is we could reference back to where we saw
that if we have two segments
that have the same length,
like segment AB and segment DE.
If we have two segments
with the same length
that they are congruent.
You can always map one
segment onto the other
with a series of rigid transformations.
The way that we could do that in this case
is we could map point B onto point E.
So this would be now I'll
put B prime right over here.
And if we just did a
transformation to do that,
if we just translated like that,
then side, woops, then side B A would,
that orange side would
be something like that.
But then we could do
another rigid transformation
that rotates about point E, or B prime,
that rotates that orange side,
and the whole triangle with it, onto DE.
In which case, once we do that
second rigid transformation,
point A will now coincide with D.
Or we could say A prime is equal to D.
But the question is,
where would C now sit?
Well, we can see the
distance between A and C.
In fact, we can use our compass for it.
The distance between A
and C is just like that.
And so since all
of these rigid transformations
preserve distance,
we know that C prime, the
point that C gets mapped to
after those first two transformations.
C prime it's distance is going
to stay the same from A prime.
So C prime is going to be some place,
some place along this
curve right over here.
We also know
that the rigid transformations
preserve angle measures.
And so we also know that
as we do the mapping,
the angle will be preserved.
So either side AC will be mapped
to this side right over
here, and if that's the case
then F would be equal to C prime,
and we would have found
our rigid transformation
based on SAS, and so therefore
the two triangles would be congruent.
But there's another possibility
that the angle gets conserved,
but side AC is mapped down here.
So there's another
possibility that side AC,
due to our rigid transformations,
or after our first set
of rigid transformations,
looks something like this.
It looks something like that.
In which case, C prime would
be mapped right over there.
And in that case,
we can just do one more
rigid transformation.
We can just do a reflection about DE,
or A prime B prime, to
reflect point C prime
over that to get right over there.
How do we know that C prime
would then be mapped to F?
Well, this angle would be preserved
due to the rigid transformation.
So as we flip it over, as we
do the reflection over DE,
the angle will be preserved.
And A prime C prime will then map to DF.
And then we'd be done.
We have just shown that
there's always a series
of rigid transformations,
as long as you meet this SAS criteria,
that can map one triangle onto the other.
And therefore, they are congruent.